so let's go to the biggest unanswerable
questions of
consciousness what is you just rolled
your eyes
i did that yeah so what is consciousness
from a neuroscience perspective
i know you i mean
uh i made notes you know because you
gave me some questions in advance and i
made notes for every single oh except
that one yeah well that one i had
what the [ __ ] when i took it out
so is there something interesting
because you're so pragmatic
is there something interesting to say
about intuition
building about consciousness or is this
something that we're just
totally clueless about that this is uh
let's focus
on the the body the brain listens to the
body the body
speaks to the brain and let's let's just
figure this piece out
and then consciousness will probably
emerge somehow after that
no i think you know well first of all i
i'll just say up front
um i am not a philosopher of
consciousness and i'm not a
neuroscientist
who focuses on consciousness i mean in
some sense i do study it because i study
affect and mood and that's that is the
um uh you know to use the phrase
that is the the hard question um of
consciousness
how is it that your brain is modeling
your body
your brain is modeling the sensory
conditions of your body
it's um and it's being updated that
model is being updated by the
sense data that's coming from your body
and it's happening continuously
your whole life and you don't feel
those sensations directly you
what you feel is a general sense of
pleasantness or unpleasantness comfort
just comfort feeling worked up feeling
calm so
we call that affect you know most people
call it mood
so how is it that your brain gives you
this very low dimensional feeling
of mood or affect when it's
presumably receiving a very high
dimensional
array of sense data and the model that
the brain is running
of the body has to be high dimensional
because
there's a lot going on in there right
you're not aware but as you're sitting
there quietly as your listeners or
our our as our viewers are sitting um
they might be working out running now or
as many of them right
here they're laying in bed smoking weed
with their eyes closed
that's fair so maybe we should say that
bit again then
so if so some people may be working out
some people may be
uh relaxing i'm relaxing but you know
even if you're sitting very still
while you're watching this or listening
to this there's a whole drama going on
inside your body
that you're largely unaware of yet your
brain makes you
aware or gives you a status report in a
sense
by virtue of these mental features of
feeling pleasant
feeling unpleasant feeling comfortable
feeling uncomfortable feeling
energetic feeling tired and so on and so
how the hell is it doing that that is
the
basic question of
of consciousness and like the status
reports seem to be
in the way we experience them seem to be
quite simple
like it doesn't feel like there's a lot
of data
yeah no there isn't so when you feel
when you feel um discomfort when you're
feeling basically like [ __ ]
you feel like [ __ ] what does that tell
you like what are you supposed to do
next
what caused it i mean the thing is not
one thing caused it
right it's multiple factors probably
influencing
your physical state your body very high
dimensional yeah
very high dimensional um and
that and the there are different
temporal scales of influence right so
um it you know the state of your gut
is not just influenced by what you ate
five minutes ago it's also
what you ate a day ago and two days ago
and and so on so
um so
i think the
you know when i'm i'm not trying to
weasel out of the question i just think
it's a it's the hardest question
actually do you think we'll ever
understand it
um as scientists
i think that we will understand it as
well
as we understand other things like
um the birth of the universe or
the you know the nature of the of the
universe i guess i i would say so i
do i think we can get to that level of
an explanation
i do actually but i think that we have
to start asking somewhat different
questions and approaching
the science somewhat differently than we
have in the past i mean it's also
possible that consciousness is much more
difficult to understand than the nature
of the universe
it is but i i wasn't necessarily saying
that it was a question that was
of equivalent complexity i was saying
that i do think that
we could get to some
i i am optimistic that i i would not
i would be very willing to invest my the
time
my time on this earth as a scientist in
trying to answer that question
if i could do it the way that i want to
do it
um not in the way that it's currently
being done so like rigorously
i don't want to say unrigorously i just
want to say that there are certain set
of assumptions that
you know scientists have what i would
call ontological commitments their
commitments about the way
the world is or the way that nature is
and they these commitments lead
scientists sometimes
blindly without they don't scientists
sometimes sometimes scientists are aware
of these commitments but sometimes
they're not
and these commitments on the list
influence how scientists
ask questions how what they measure how
they measure
and i i just have very different views
than a lot of my colleagues about the
ways to approach this not everybody
but um but the way that i would approach
it would be different
and it would cost more
and it would take longer it doesn't fit
very
well into the current incentive
structure of science and so
do i think that doing science the way
science is currently done with the
budget that it currently has and the
incentive structure that it currently
has will we have an answer no i think
absolutely not good luck is what i would
say
you